welcome to this video playing gosh it's
yet enough one thing is this Russia to
see at the north yes when NASA from
Uzbekistan right yes you see for g6 this
is a bit of a strange line interesting I
will saw that before this kind of
combination okay let's just develop a
normal fashion at them looks a bit of
bit like a ghoul felt but then yeah with
97 okay so what is he doing here is six
try to take him and then be five but
this looks are really really really
crappy okay let's play a generally
useful moves okay something entirely
different
okay I should speed up here it's just
yeah an irregular set up for black and
not not a particularly good one but it's
useless to to spend ages just trying to
show just try to make a decent move some
in rather not too too much time council
so maybe not five trying to do that okay
but some drop this back to take him but
I still maintain pretty good control all
over this position gap is that I Scott
the quite ugly bishop on c8 how to
proceed he's got this idea to play em
ups to play a five of course
some activate this night see for some
good square yeah I can just dig so he's
taking here and taking the rook at the
decking f 5b seven is hanging down hmm
ok
so we both have some weaknesses but then
I going to win c6 maybe he's getting a 3
or something like like if like I'm may
be ending up with them with a neck strap
on only five or something
yeah okay if I give heartache take hey
Scotty is getting me3 at the end it's
not helping
you know I've got slightly very slightly
the more actual position permits checks
of course some very drawers okay draw
our third game drawn yeah simply nothing
going on and yeah okay why should really
get something against this not
particularly great opening but this was
a bit miss time maybe night see for him
maybe night see phone around here is the
critical the critical point of this game
is still got this Betsy admission but
the way it did went down he managed to
exchange here and if you wouldn't have
played b6 here I'm not quite sure about
this position the somme simply leads to
the simplification of the game and
there's simply nothing happening I need
to I need to do something else here
maybe here maybe 95 is not well timed if
he goes a five um I have be five so
maybe I need to start with something
like this and a five I just go be five
or can take he doesn't have something to
capture only five yeah this is good
actually this simply be seven hanging so
I five is just just a bad move yeah this
is how I need to play and then just try
to gradually improve the position I
think white should be a bit a bit better
because of the bad bishop but it's still
quite resilient for blood the way it was
played there was just nothing
okay thanks for watching